start with a top story it's called
reparations now that would be taking
large sums of money and redistributing
those funds to African Americans that
would mean every American would pay
instead of you know spreading wealth
based on need money would be allocated
to individuals purely based on the issue
of race now the premise according to the
left would be to compensate for the
evils of slavery now first the country
simply cannot afford the billions and
billions of dollars and trillions of
dollars that it would likely take to
allocate and ultimately it is a punitive
measure and one that will even further
divide a country that is already deeply
divided those who support reparations
believe that America is an evil country
filled to the brim with generations of
bad people and while no intelligent
person let me be clear denies the evils
of slavery it would be a great Injustice
to ignore all the progress this country
has made on racial issues and other
issues which is the beauty of our great
Constitution it has provided all of us a
road map that we can right wrongs and
correct injustices we've made a lot of
progress we still have a long way to go
but but no doubt reparations and it is
an extreme policy based on divisive
racial politics and if you think that it
is a far-fetched pipe dream you better
think again because common sense in
America is now becoming a thing in the
past common sense I could save for maybe
half the country is pretty much dead and
now Democrats in Congress they are
planning a 14. listen this not million
not bill or 14 trillion dollar
reparations plan watch this
our country was not founded on the
principle that all people are created
equal the media focuses on this one
kidnapped person
usually White
the US stole
12 million people this is an opportunity
for Congress to confront our nation's
racist history of slavery and white
supremacy that continues to really grow
and fester within all corners of our
country our education system have
trained us to love and worship our
oppressor and our slave master and to do
everything we can to work within its
structure and its systems to upload to
uphold our continued oppression so when
we talk about the disproportionate
impact of heart disease high blood
pressure diabetes
stress when we talk about that it's
directly connected to our historical
oppression in this country all right now
keep in mind the entire U.S budget is
around six trillion dollars way too high
already they want an additional 14
trillion dollars just for reparations
and by the way they're not going to get
it from billionaires if you look at the
cumulative wealth of every single
billionaire in the country it is a mere
five trillion dollars if they
confiscated every single Cent so make no
mistake this money is coming from your
pocket every American's pocket and it
won't matter whether you're a first
generation immigrant or a working class
American or a Native American or a
low-income earner from around the
country these members of Congress want
to penalize everybody in the country
simply because you were born with the
wrong ethnicity now it's it is not fair
to ask why families in America that have
no connection at all to any past
generational involvement in slavery why
should they be forced to pay massive
sums of money when neither they nor any
family member in the past had any
involvement at all with slavery now of
course the woke city of San Francisco
they have already drafted a plan they
want to give five million dollars to all
50 000 black residents in that City
other proposals include quote grants to
buy and maintain homes to exempting
African-American businesses from paying
taxes and it's not just San Francisco
it's Cal in California now you've got
New York and New Jersey and Illinois
they're all developing similar plans and
this might soon become a reality
according to the Democratic party it is
the it is the least the evil American
taxpayers can do now ultimately it is a
political Ploy from Democrats why
because they like to see America divided
they want to divide us on the issue of
race and age sex and gender in order to
energize their radical base this isn't
about truth it's not about logic it's
not about fairness it's not about Equity
it's about winning elections by
vilifying in many cases here innocent
people over the weekend we witnessed Joe
Biden he went down to Howard University
and proclaimed that white supremacy is
the greatest Terror threat in the entire
world here's what he said
stand up against the poison
the white supremacists I did my
inaugural address to a single out as the
most dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy
[Music]
and I'm not saying this because I'm at a
black hpcu
I say Wherever I Go
that's the same Joe Biden you might all
recall I talked about it during the
election in 2020 that partnered with the
former klansman Robert KKK Byrd and he
tried to stop the integration of public
schools because in his words he did not
want public schools to become quote
racial jungles that was Joe Biden so
maybe he could pay the reparations now
it's not Isis as the biggest threat it's
not Al Qaeda it's not gang members and
Chicago shooting dozens of innocent
African-American
African-American citizens every weekend
according to Joe and most Democrats the
ambiguous threat of white supremacy is
the most dire crisis of our time now no
doubt about it white supremacy is evil
most Americans see it as evil and most
Americans believe it has no place in
America but Democrats now are magnifying
this for political gain most Americans
see white Supremacy as ignorant and evil
and in turn they are ignoring real
problems look at the Decades of
democratic rule in places like Baltimore
Philadelphia Chicago New York the
quality of life for many is abysmal
we're the Democrats span as widespread
violence is erupting in cities like
Chicago and New York and and shootings
and people murdered every single weekend
what are they doing to fix the failing
public schools of many minorities in
this country I'll take the city of
Baltimore for example 23 City schools
and not one single student proficient in
math not one we have failed these
children many minority children and they
don't lift a finger to help fix the
system the Democrats don't seem to care
so long as they are winning elections
keeping power and for the left that's
all that matters hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else